hello I'm a nostalgic red guy remember
it so you don't have to if you watch my
show then you know that I often make fun
of cliches though the annoying will plot
points and reoccurring moments that
never seem to evolve no matter how many
times we use them but for as much as I
bitch about them there actually are a
fair amount of cool cliches these are
the moments you've seen a million times
before but for some reason you never get
tired of they were awesome when they
first appeared and they're still awesome
now and nothing can never make them
deteriorate their awesomeness what do
you laugh at them or take them seriously
they're always a ton of fun to watch
and so I'm honoring the top 11 greatest
cliches that ever existed why top 11
because I had my own cliche that will
never die
so sit back and enjoy the top 11 coolest
cliche
number one holding the gun sideways this
is also known as gangsta style and it is
completely pointless there is no reason
to hold the gun sideways it doesn't help
your aim it doesn't make the bullet go
any faster so what I'll do it because it
looks friggin awesome that's why dota PS
I'm not even sure why it looks awesome
maybe a shows that the killer is just so
laid back and cool but he doesn't even
need to point the gun up all the way
like fuck you you're not even worth
using the sight on this gun this method
has been used so much that they satirise
it everywhere one of the most memorable
is it's super bad break yourself fool
and a more recent sentire was in
daylight god no he turned it sideways
kill shot that's a kill shot whatever
reason people do it it just looks bad
ass even if it does make no sense
whatsoever
kill shot that's a kill shot Norton the
sexy crowd nobody in movies ever has a
traditional cry where they start
sniffing and snorting and can barely
talk no no they have the sexy cry that
one single tear that comes down while
the rest of their face shows no emotion
oh yeah
there's two recent film series in
particular they use this a lot when was
the new Star Wars movies where Anakin is
evil and angry but sad and the other is
Lord of the Rings good god everybody
cried in this movie the only two people
had the sexy cry
one was Frodo which was framed so
over-the-top you swear was the cover to
a new age album
and the other is Arwen who i swear to
god her only purpose was to ride horses
and cry and every scene that's what
she's doing
right a horse cry ride a horse cry even
when it seems like there's no reason to
do it she cries and every time she
doesn't it's the sexy cry she's
practically perfected it oh wait getting
some hesitation there you go sexy cry oh
yeah I don't know why people don't get
snot-nosed and puffy I when they cry in
movies but if they did we wouldn't have
this wonderful cliche what are you gonna
cry now come on cry baby gotta cry oh my
god the past every character has a dark
tormenting past that always follows them
into the present it either involves
something the character is done well the
death of a family member for some reason
that character is usually the father you
killed my father
you killed my father you killed my
father you killed my father
why is it always the father and never
the mother it's like yeah bitch all you
did was push me out what the hell do I
owe you I don't know but whatever the
reason it's always a touchy subject
which requires our main character to
always brood away from the crowd as the
one curious onlooker wants to understand
I always wanted to see a back story that
combined all the back stories by
creating the ultimate past something
like blades mother was attacked by a
vampire while she was pregnant he's more
machine than man tune killed his brother
and along the way he just happened to
become the most powerful man of the
state now that would be an awesome movie
like they always say the dreams of the
past create the realities of the future
as well as one of my all-time favorite
cliches how did my father die drop the
piano on his head hurry
the dramatic choir this is one the
composer of a film decides he or she
wants the movie to sound more epic so
full-on choir is brought in to sing
straight-up gibberish that sounds like
some sort of dead language
sometimes they use a real language like
in Hunchback of Notre Dom they really
aren't sing laugh
Allen lure the Rings are actually
singing elvish what's next a Star Trek
choir singing Klingon would knock look
ma boom bah Oh knock knock knock knock
knock hey boo Brock never play that
again but for the most part it's just
made-up words you can see this a lot in
film trailers in fact there's actually
musicians now who specifically
specialize in only writing songs from
movie trailers and you can guarantee if
it's an action film there's almost
always going to be a quiet
sometimes they use straight-up English
but try to make it sound like it's a
foreign language that's really weird
sometimes the most simple ones are the
most effective for example film composer
Danny Elfman uses choirs all the time
but what do they usually say
he literally has the choir do all the
oohs and ahhs for you no need for the
audience to participate the movie is
praising itself already my favorite in
terms of comedic ones though is at the
end of airplane when the dramatic choir
is literally so dramatic that they can't
even make the very last note
what can I say I'm a sucker for choirs
and looks like most of America is too
number seven
mano-a-mano aka chapstick this is what
our hero is going through like a
bajillion bad guys which always results
in the one-on-one battle with our main
villain for some reason the main villain
always seems to be the longest person to
fight to how can they can just use that
person to begin with clearly that was
the strongest opponent but oh well
there's another cliche that evolves from
this which I like to call Chow sting
this is when the hero and villain stare
each other down and just lunge after
each other
it's practically caveman like it's pure
emotion building as they run down an
often very long pathway we saw them one
for each other in The Count of Monte
Cristo
we saw them leap for each other the
planet eh we make but my favorite and by
far the goofiest is from Mission
Impossible too when our enemies raced
after each other on motorcycles and
literally propel themselves crashing
into the air yeah five fractured bones
later maybe you can fight like that I
just love how they were both thinking
the exact same thing that they were
going to end up in the air crashing into
one another like they both
coincidentally said to themselves
motorcycles aren't enough somehow I'm
gonna get myself into the air I don't
know how I'm just so filled with
wreckage your emotion coming out in one
solid charge that's a cliche that's
we're seeing a few times more
number six things blowing in the wind
this is why so many heroes and villains
work such long clothing because it looks
friggin awesome when it's blowing in the
wind help the invention of the Cape has
no real purpose it's just there to look
cool in reality that thing would get in
the way if you were ever trying to fight
you trip over it all the time but in
movies it just makes the motion of our
hero look all the more flowing they're
far more cool but to be fair it looks
pretty intimidating on villains too I
think I first started to realize how
good they look when Nicholas Cage
stepped out and face off all I could say
to myself was I want that fucking coat
and a giant fan to follow me around all
the time but women are left out of the
loop either in fact they can often get
away with it a little more long hair
long dresses long scars whatever they're
practically designed to look cool when
the wind is blowing so how long will it
take for this cliche to get so old that
we're sick to death of it my friend
is blowing in the wind the answer is
blowin
number five the explosion just a few
feet away if anyone has ever been around
a wheel explosion you know how powerful
it is as well as how definite it is
nobody can just stand around while an
explosion goes on you need to fly up in
the air or your ears would explode from
the sound yet we constantly see people
run walk and even just stand perfectly
still while they happen my favorite are
the ones where they don't even turn
around as if to say yeah I know it's
there but I'm just too badass to turn
around and look at it what you think I
don't see explosions I do all the time
they bore me now no matter how
over-the-top they try everything like
how about when Keanu Reeves outrun a
friggin mushroom cloud in chain reaction
indeed we forget the world's strongest
fridge in the last Indiana Jones movie
yeah your house would be torn apart but
is your popsicles would stay safe in the
icebox isn't that good to know
explosions are awesome but they just
don't seem to have as big of threatened
we almost ignore them even though the
new film the other guys they satirize
how literally blown out of proportion
they are I walk away at movies without
fletchie when it explodes behind man
there's no way the movie industry is
completely responsible for the way they
portray explosion well it still looks
neat it makes our heroes look tougher
and our villains much more menacing cuz
let's be honest anyone looks tough when
they can honestly look at a giant ball
of fire and smoke and simply other scene
it
number four the simple shouting of God
why do so many people shout this anyway
it's so basic and yet it convey so much
I guess as humans we just want things to
go going to plan we always want to hear
yes so whenever we hear oh no we
immediately think Oh something was
suggested that resulted that make a
different response that immediately
creates drama and that's bad I better
watch this ah it's like a gut reaction
we hear the word know when we instantly
associated with something going wrong
yes good oh damn there's a lot of famous
nose out there probably the most notably
when Luke Skywalker finds out his daddy
is my absolute favorite though is in
Tombstone which is already a pretty
romanticize film but it was also one of
my all-time favorite scenes were white
herb just cracks no no what are you
doing no bitch yo who do not die
laughing at that it's one of the most
over-the-top scenes ever yo and he
doesn't even stop there he just keeps
saying it over and over and over I have
a negative impulse to the scenario bulls
to this scenario
and of course the ultimate puss out
moment in any Star Wars movie and that's
saying a lot this especially pissed
people off because now Darth Vader has
his Sunnah he's badass he's the
character we all recognize it wasn't why
me and again anymore and what's the
first thing he says where's my
girlfriend I want to see my girlfriend
what she's dead hell mr. bill sounded
more butch than you so if the art of
drama could be reduced down to simply
one word I think we all know what it
would be number three
the evil laugh again half of the time it
almost seems like there's no reason for
it something goes right for the bad guy
and they always let out a gush of evil
laughter I mean it's not like if
something goes good for someone else
they let out insanely loud laughter oh
hey I found my lost state ID
for whatever the reason it's always
great and there had been some real
fantastic evil laughs like remember Gary
Oldman and the remake of Dracula how
about Jabba the Hutt's evil chuckle and
Return of the Jedi
the Joker good god every lab from every
variation of the character was just
awesome
these are Michael Jackson new if you
want a music videos about zombies to end
right you need a Vincent Price cast this
too has been satirized to death
particularly in the Austin Powers movies
if they ask the question what does a
villain do after they stop laughing yeah
it's goofy but what is done right it's
sweet laughter to our use and can pretty
much put a smile on anybody's face
number two walking in a straight line
this shows that the group is together
and are ready to kick some ass something
about the strength and numbers and
organizations just makes this scene look
so awesome I think just about any group
of people can do this and they can look
great
hell we even did it in you can Xion and
we look pretty cool Wow funny but even
wider like Anakin suddenly grow some
balls when he has a line of soldiers
behind and look at him here a little
pipsqueak who switches sides in a
millisecond and starts crying over where
it way but once you put a straight line
of people behind him holy shit he's
suddenly badass I'm actually looking
forward to children being slaughtered
the movie that probably explain this the
most again was tombstone they like this
straight line so much that they actually
closed out the movie with it and can you
blame them it's frigging cool even in
movies like x-men 3 just standing in a
straight line looks pretty hardcore I
gotta admit I don't see this all the
time but when I do it always upgrades
the movie's awesome levels it looks
tough intimidating and organized you
know group means business when they all
stand together and it always makes for
one of the coolest if not the coolest
moment of them
number one fullest cliche is slow motion
well yeah pretty basic isn't it
fight scenes close-ups whatever
everything seems to look better in slow
motion there have been online videos
comedic sketches even entire show is
just dedicated to how things look in
slow-mo it's just so much more grand and
powerful when you can see the movement
of every little part on-screen there's
almost a rhythm to it like a dance or a
ballet almost anything can look cool in
slow-mo well again almost anything now
recently there's been sort of a weird
twist where some directors slowed the
movie down and then speed it up as it to
make up for lost time or something I
never saw the point of it the slow-mo
itself is so friggin sweet that after
watching him regular motions already
going to seem like fast motion so I
speed it up either way as long as the
slow-mo is there it's always going to
look fan-friggin'-tastic it makes
everything look more massive more
sweeping and of course more awesome
there's no telling how long this cliche
has been around but judging how long
we've been using it it's showing no sign
of slowing down slow motion the coolest
cliche of all time and those are my top
11 coolest cliches I hope you enjoyed
them and well I was gonna close off
showing what the cliche yeah but my
guess is you're probably tired with them
by now
you
yo